hello everyone on this day of prayer
when we tried to understand God's plan
in our pain to George's family and
friends
Jenna and I know that deep hole in your
hearts when you bury a piece in their
soul deep in this earth as I've said to
you privately we know we know you will
never feel the same again for most
people and unless you feel now will
slowly turn day after day season after
season into purpose through the memory
of the one they lost for you that day
has come before you can fully grieve and
unlike most you must grieve in public
it's a burden a burden that is now your
purpose to change the world for the
better the name of George Floyd
like so many others I've watched with
awe as you some of the absolute courage
to channels God's grace and show the
good man George was search to spur
justice to long dormant to move millions
to act peacefully purposely but among
all the people around the world who feel
connected to this tragedy are the ones
who lost something and can never ever be
replaced - George's children and
grandchild I know you miss your dad and
your granddad Louisiana as I said to you
when I started yesterday you're so brave
daddy's looking down he's so proud of
you
I know you missed that bear hug that
only he could give the pure joy riding
on his shoulders so you could touch the
sky the countless hours he spent playing
any game you want it because your smile
your laugh your love is the only thing
that mattered at the moment I know you
have a lot of questions honey no child
should have to ask questions that too
many black children have had to ask for
generations why why is daddy killed
I'm looking through your eyes we should
also be asking ourselves why the answer
is so often too cruel and painful why in
this nation do too many black Americans
wake up knowing that they could lose
their life and the course of just living
their life why it is justice that roll
like a river or righteousness like a
mighty stream
why amazing gentlemen you can't turn
away we must not turn away we cannot
lead this moment thinking we can once
again turn away from racism that stings
that our very soul from systemic abuse
still plagues American life as Thurgood
Marshall once implored quote America
must dissent from indifference
it must dissent from fear the hatred and
the mistrust
we must dissent because America can do
better because America has no choice but
to do better I grew up with Catholic
Social Doctrine which taught me faith
without works is dead
and you'll know us by what we do ladies
and gentlemen you've got to deal with
the denial the promise of this nation to
so many people for so long it's about
who we are what we believe and maybe
most importantly who we want to be so
I'm sure that all men and women are not
only created evil but are treated
equally we can heal this nation's wounds
and remember it's pain that Callos the
heart and forget
I know Reverend Sharpton is there and
you soon with you today rev and watch
you speak from ecclesiastic last week in
Minnesota chapter 3 verse 1 everything
there is a time and a purpose and a
season under the heavens today now is
the time the purpose the season to
listen and heal now is the time for
racial justice that's the answer we must
give to our children when they ask why
because when there is justice for George
Floyd we will truly be on our way to
racial justice in America and then as
you said gianna your daddy will have
changed the world may God be with you
George Floyd and your family and the
words of a hymn from my church based on
the 91st song may he raise you up on
eagle's wings bear you on the breath of
dawn
and make you to shine like the Sun and
hold you in the palm of his head
god bless you all god bless you
[Applause]